مره على زلزال كهرمان مراش بايامه وساعاته
الطوال وردت كئيبه على العالقين تحت
الركان وعلى المشردين والناجين في الساحات
والشوارع والخيام
وعلى فرق الانقاذ التي تسابق الزمن في
مهمه
تتوقف على نجاحها حياه الناس هنا حيث اقف
جنب غربي تركيا بدا كل شيء هزه شديده
تبعتها اخرى لم تعترف بحدود السياسه ولا
بحواجز اللغه فوحدت بين الاتراك والسوريين
في الماساه وتركتهم يلملمون الجراح
دقائق قليله دمرت شوارع باكملها وبدلت
ملامح مدن وغيرت جغرافيه المكان حصيله
قتلى بعشرات الالاف وملايين المشردين
مئه وثمانون ثانيه تخلخلت فيها طبقات
الارض فعبثت بحياه الملايين وتساوى فيها
الناس في محنتهم ومبيتهم وماكلهم عند
الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه من فجر الاثنين
السادس من فبراير شباط هكذا بدت الصوره
حجب غزق الليل حجم الدمار وما هي الا
سويعات حتى تكشف ما احدثته الهزه من ادرار
ويا له من دمار تسارع عداد القتلى بدا
بالمئات وما لبث ان قفز الى الالاف من
الشعب التركي يعيش اقصى ايام تاريخه
الزلزالان الكبيران الضياء الى اضرار
كبيره جدا في عشر محافظات تركيه تضم نحو
ثلاثه عشر مليون ونصف مليون مواطن تركي
خبراء الزلازل وصفوا الزلزالين بانهما
استثنائيان ولا مثيل لهما في العالم
عند مقارنه هذين الزلزالين باشباههما
فانهما الديال حدوث شقوق ارضيه في منطقه
جغرافيه واسعه جدا وهو ما ادى الى تعاظم
الدمار
الدمار الهائل ذاته امتد الى الشمال
السوري تزامن مع منخفض جوي قارس البروده
ونقص شديد في معدات البحث والانقاذ
زاد من معاناه السوريين المكلومين بويلات
الحرب تعقيدات السياسه وما نظر اليه على
انه بخل من المجتمع الدولي وتاخر في ارسال
المساعدات على قلتها على ضفتي الحدود
تتشابه قصص الضحايا والناجين وان اختلفت
ظروف الدولتين وامكاناتهما في اسوء كارثه
تضرب المنطقه منذ قرن من الزمان
ما حدث هنا في بؤره الزلزال هو اسوا حدث
تشهده المنطقه خلال المئه عام
اجبر الزلزال مئات الالاف من الاتراك على
المبيت في العراء واصبحت الحكومه ومعها
جيش من المتطوعين رعيا بابسط حاجياتهم من
اكل وشرب ووسائل تدفئه
وفي سوريا اعاد الزلزال الى الاذهان مشاهد
النزوح بعد تدمير حلبه وادلب ليس
بالبراميل المتفجره هذه المره لكن بسبب
قوه قاهره لا تقبل التفاوض
تقاطعت على تركيا قوافل المساعدات وفرق
الانقاذ ونهجه الالسن بالدعوات وبصلوات
المتضامنين في حين كان الشمال السوري اقل
حظا واقل استقبالا للدعم وهذا باعتراف
الامم المتحده التي قالت ان المجتمع
الدولي خذل السوريين في تصريح لم يكن
مفاجئا
طالعين
[موسيقى]
يا الله
بعد مرور اسبوع لم تتوقف عمليات الانقاذ
فرق بحث تغلب التعب وتثابر رغم قسوه الطقس
وقله النوم مجهود كوفي بانتشال الرضع
والشيوخ وما بينهما من اعمار في كابه
المشهد وسوداويته قصص ملهمه تطفي لمسه
الانسانيه جميله ونبيله على صوره حزينه
رسمها الزلزال
سنوات طويله وربما عقود ستحتاجها تركيا
وشمال السوري للتعافي من اثار الزلزال
فتداعياته ستبقى محفوره في ذاكره اجيال
بكاملها وندوبه العميقه ستبقى باديه لكن
للبشر قدره عجيبه على التاقلم ونفض الغبار
والمضي قدما والعوده من جديد
كهرمان مراش